j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public vous savez on tente le plus
souvent possible de le décaler
volontairement de l'actualité du jour il
concerne cette campagne de publicité de
l'ADM qui a été diffusée quelques jours
avant le Black Friday donc ça fait un
peu plus de de 2 semaines l'agence de la
transition écologique qui metett en
scène vous vous en souvenez sans doute
des dévendeurs chargés d'inciter les
consommateurs à ne plus acheter du neuf
au profit du recyclé bonne idée insister
à la à la seconde main et pourtant la
pub provoque une polémique au sein même
du gouvernement retour sur un pâte à
caisse révélateur des hésitations face à
l'urgence climatique avec Flora sauvage
vous prendriez lequel vous honnêtement
ouais aucun des deux mais c'est à moins
70 % franchement pour un vendeur vous
êtes pas ah non pas du tout moi je suis
dévendeur et je vous conseille le moins
100% il y a moins 100 % bah oui le vôtre
il est très
bien je peux hésitez pas si vous avez
besoin que je vous déconseille d'autres
achat ça soulagera les ressources de la
planète e et vos placards réalisé par
laadem l'agence de la transition
écologique quatre clips incitant les
Français à la sobriété ont suscité la
colère des commerçants en plein Black
Friday c'est ce discours de décroissance
en fait qui nous a choqué nous on est
pour une croissance parce que là la
croissance c'est de l'emploi c'est de
l'activité économique on peut être pour
une autre croissance une croissance plus
responsable et dans ce cas-là nous nous
aurions aimé travailler avec la laadem
pour soutenir pourquoi pas du made in
France en pleine sinistrose du secteur
de l'habillement alors que près de la
moitié des commerces indépendants ont
enregistré un recul de plus de 20 % de
leur chiffre d'affaires sur un an le
ministre de l'Économie Bruno l maire
déplore le message véhiculé dans la
campagne de l'ADEM trouve pas ça très
habile vis-à-vis du commerce physique et
qui se bat que nous soutenons en
particulier en centre-ville c'est une
façon de faire une promotion indirect du
commerce dématérialisé autre son de
cloche du ministre de la transition
écologique face à la polémique
Christophe Béchu assumeus dans une
journée normale comme aujourd'hui il y a
20000 spots télé qui sont diffusés sur
nos Andes 53 spots sur les 20000 de la
journée d'aujourd'hui c'est la campagne
que vous décrivez 0,2 % que 02 % du
temps d'antennes publicitaires soi
consacré à se demander si tous les
achats sont utiles franchement vu les
enjeux de transition écologique ça ne me
semble pas déraisonnable à l'heure où
chaque Français achète 48 vêtements par
an en moyenne la polémique autour de
l'appel à la sobriété lancé par laadè
illustre les difficultés de l'exécutif à
transmettre un message clair sur
l'écologie plus surveiller d' de France
Black Friday Noël comment limiter notre
consommation comment concilier peut-on
concilier transition écologique et
croissance c'est le thème de notre débat
avec pascalbell bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous vous êtes directrice
associée chez C société de conseil en
marketing spécialisé en en data science
en analyse des des données Rémy Godo
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes rédacteur
en chef de l'opinion et Guillaume Copin
bonsoir et bienvenue chargé de Play
clima chez Oxfam France Mathieu
croissand d'au évidemment est resté à
mes côtés je rebondis sur le sujet qui
nous rappelle cette campagne de de de
l'ADEM les dévendeurs juste avant le
Black Friday votre avis parce qu'elle
est belle est-ce que c'était une bonne
idée alors en effet la
publicité a été intéressante elle avait
un message qui était clair en effet
c'est tombé pile au moment où il y avait
le Black Friday donc on comprend qu'il y
a des artisans et des commerçants qui en
effet ont perdu beaucoup de chiffrre
d'affaires sur 2023 donc ne sois pas
très content que cette publicité soit
faite à ce moment-là mais finalement on
a un effet strzon c'est-à-dire qu'on a
tellement barbon c'est ça étudé
c'estàdire que c'est finalement tout le
monde en a parlé c'est-à-dire que
finalement ce spot a été beaucoup plus
diffusé que ce qu'ilaurait été s'il y
avait pas eu de débat et notamment dans
tous les journals télévisés donc
finalement les consommateurs l'ont
beaucoup plus vu que s'il y avait pas eu
de débat donc ceux qui ne voulaient pas
qu'il soit mis en avant aurait mieux
fait de ne pas faire de débat j'avoue je
me souviens plus c'était quoi lese fait
barbaress raison c'est pas quoi le point
de départ c'était une polémique cétait
en fait oui enfin en tous les cas
derrière c'est que alors pourquoi
barbaraésente oui sans doute il y a eu
un un photo ses proi V avait qu'elle
avait voulu cacher c'est ce que en
voulant la cacher et en voulant la faire
supprimer elle a donné beaucoup plus de
de publicité voz je me souvenais plus de
de ça l'effet l'effet Barbaras rés il y
a eu effectivement alors des réactions
et ce qui a sans doute provoqué on va
parler des réactions politiques mais il
y a aussi le l'alliance du commerce
l'Union des industries textiles l'Union
des Industries modes et qui menace de de
porter plainte et migodo il faut
expliquer pourquoi il y a il y a c'est
un secteur qui sou'ffre particulièrement
alors c'est un secteur qui sou'ffre
particulièrement et c'est un sujet de
fait assez important parce que pour ces
gens-là c'est leur activité qui est mis
entre guillemets un peu en cause et puis
ça va beaucoup plus loin parce que
derrière il y a il y a toute la question
un peu morale un peu philosophique de
quoi on a besoin qu'est-ce qui fait le
bonheur des consommateurs est-ce que le
bonheur est dans la surconsommation
est-ce que le bonheur est dans le fait
de sa acheter un 5è polo même si on en a
quatre et ça c'est des questions très
personnelles légitimes qui sont mis sur
la place voilà qui sont mis sur la place
publicque mais là on vous dit un peu
grosso modo que c'est pas bien ah vous
dites qu'on est encore dans le discours
de culpabilisation de culpabilisation
mais là on vous fait comprendre que pour
sauver la planète il faut pas avoir un
5è polo donc c'est quel bien sûr le polo
c'est un peu anecdotique mais c'est ça
veut dire quelque chose d'assez profond
et puis surtout ça veut dire quelque
chose sur notre modèle économique est-ce
que on est en phase de transition donc
on va pass c'est d'un modèle à un autre
modèle est-ce que l'autre modèle doit se
passer de la croissance est-ce que la la
consommation c'est pas bien tel qu'on la
pratique aujourd'hui donc c'est quand
même à raison c'est des questions
fondamentales ouis et c'est pour ça que
ce débat nous nous a intéressé au-delà
de de de la question très actuelle là
des prochaines semaines est-ce qu'on
peut faire des cadeaux de Noël faire
plaisir à nos enfants petits enfants et
tout temps limitant notre consommation
ça pose la question de la seconde main
dont on va largement parler dans ce dans
ce débat on parlait des de de ce secteur
du du commerce et de l'habillement
particulièrement 621 commerces de la
personne c'est le terme employé qui ont
disparu entre 2020 et 2023 à Paris avec
des enseignes je vais citer camailleux
GAB Gosport Sant Marina kouille depuis
la fin de l'année 2022 il y a beaucoup
de magasins de prêt à porter qui se sont
retrouvés en redressement ou en
liquidation judiciaire Guillaume
Compin au-delà de l'objectif est-ce que
c'était maladroit de la part de laadem
de d'intégrer puisquil y avait plusieurs
spots ce secteur de de l'habillement qui
souffre particulièrement bah ce qui est
clair c'est que euh selon nous il y a il
y a un enjeu global pour toute la
l'industrie qu'elle soit en ligne ou pas
de réduire euh le niveau de de vente de
des produits qui peuvent avoir un impact
extrêmement polluant sur la planète
après oui évidemment que il y a une
distinction entre des grandes
multinationales qui vendent des millions
et des millions de produits chaque jour
en ligne et le petit commerce local qui
parfois fait vivre euh sa sa petite
ville son village donc je sais pas c'est
maladroit après clairement pour nous il
faut cibler avant tout des les grandes
multinationales qui vont déverser des
quantités astronomiques de produits
parfois des produits de première
nécessité dont on a besoin mais parfois
aussi des désirs artificiels qui sont
générés notamment par la publicité et
alors même si parfois on n'est pas
d'accord avec Monsieur Béchu là pour le
coup je je j'abonde complètement dans
son sens et alors peut-être c'est une
stratégie concertée avec Bruno Lemer
pour les faest trésand et faire encore
plus connaître ce spot pas
sûr Mathieu si on remonte un peu sur les
conséquences que de cette campagne de de
l'ADEM cette tournure très politique
qu'est-ce qu'on pe dire on a bien failli
frôler la crise gouvernementale pour des
spots de 30 secondes quand même he car
ces clips n'ont pas seulement opposé le
ministre de la transition écologique
Christophe Béchu et son homologue de
Bercy Bruno le MERER mais ils ont même
agacé en hautlieu à Matignon et même
Emmanuel Macron le site politico le
révélit la semaine dernière les services
de la première ministre non que très peu
goûté cette initiative dont ils n'avait
pas été informés en même est-ce qu'ils
sont obligés de valider toutes les les
campagnes de tous les ministères de tous
les organismes publics et par public bon
courage ça va faire du boulot et puis
idem à l'Élysée où selon politico le
président de la République en personne
n'avait pas hésité à qualifier la
campagne de conneries devant plusieurs
élus vous savez quand il avait rassemblé
des maires au palais alors Christophe
Béchu n'a trouvé du réconfort qu'auprès
de ses amis du parti horizon dans la
majorité parti horizon dont il est
secrétaire général a commencé par
Édouard Philippe qui a trouvé
remarquable la tribune que le ministre a
publié la semaine dernière dans le monde
et puis sinon il a trouvé du soutien
aussi auprès de certaines ONG et et dans
une partie de de l'opposition ouais pe
peut-on parler d'une erreur de la part
de de Christophe Béchu moi je pense pas
je pense que Béchu a raison sa tribune
publiée dans le monde la semaine
dernière avait le mérite d'afficher une
position claire pour une fois dont les
clips de laadem ne sont qu'une
illustration parce qu'en invitant les
Français à plus de sobriété dans leur
consommation c'estd à trouver un chemin
vers une économie plus circulaire comme
il l'écrivait une économie qui réutilise
davantage les ressources au lieu de les
extraire de les utiliser et de les jeter
et ben le ministre qui assume un
changement de modèle c'est nouveau hein
selon ses mots ben il est dans son rôle
il suit le cap le cap que qui lui a fixé
ben vous vous souvenez du candidat à la
présidentielle emmanu Maon souv dans son
discours de Marseille dans Entre Deux
Tours où il avait déclaré que ce
quinquena sera écologique ou ne sera pas
alors pourquoi ça coince qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé depuis parce qu'il faut
passer de la parole aux actes et qu'on
ne sort de l'ambigué qu'à son détriment
vous le savez or si la transition
écologique peut et même doit
s'accompagner être accompagné en tout
cas elle se conjugue mal avec le
traditionnel en même temps personne au
sommet d'État n'a su pour l'instant
faire du nécessaire changement de mon
comportement autre chose que quelque
chose de subi et de sacrificiel en gros
on fixe des objectifs une planification
pour pouvoir dire on est dans les clous
mais on n pas de grand récit théorique
ou pratique qui positivent cette
révolution c'est ce que tente à sa façon
de faire sans doute Christophe Béchu
après des débuts quand même tâonnants il
le fait peut-être avec une certaine
maladresse pour ce qui concerne les
clips de l'ADEM comme il l'a reconnu
lui-même mais avec un mérite je trou
trouve celui d'affirmer une ambition
alors ça ça pose effectivement la
question de l'ambition je veux bien vous
entendre tiens là-dessus Remy Godo
l'ambition d'Emmanuel Macron le le les
contradictions entre on peut même
remonter au make our planet great again
au tout début de son premier kakena et
et ce qu'il a effectivement fait depuis
depuis 7 ans qu'il est au pouvoir moi je
suis un peu plus dur que que Mathieu
même si je partage son analyse c'est que
je pense qu'il y a le gouvernement est
un peu pris en flagrant des lits
d'incohérence HM et on l'a déjà vu dans
à d'autres reprises sur par exemple sur
la taxe carbone si vous voulez il y a
une logique politique et il y a une
logique économique la logique économique
c'est que il va falloir transformer la
la croissance mais vous ne pouvez pas
arrêter la croissance Bruno Le Maire il
se bat tous les jours pour qu'il y ait
plus de croissance parce que plus de
croissance c'est moins de chômage plus
de pouvoir d'achat et donc bah c'est
c'est c'est son job et là vous avez
quelqu'un qui lui dit bah non la
croissance c'est pas ça qu'il faut faire
et donc ben oui mais alors comment on
fait s'il y a pas de croissance est-ce
qu'il faut se battre pour le pouvoir
d'achat parce que finalement la
meilleure manière de consommer moins
c'est de se dire qu'on n' pas l'argent
pour à gaspiller pour acheter des choses
qui sont inutiles et vous voyez qu'on
rentre dans une logique que le
gouvernement ne peut pas accepter
Emmanuel Macron bah il affiche son côté
pro buusiness les entreprises elles sont
là pour euh bah pour faire de la
croissance il y a une autre chose c'est
que le c'est compliqué parce que le
capitalisme l'économie de marché dans
laquelle on est les consommateurs votent
tous les jours donc les consommateurs
ils vont aller chez Shine ils vont
consommer shine on rappelle que c'est la
la marque chinoise symbole de l'ultra
fast fashion aujourd'huiultra fast
fashion avec tout le côté négatif c'est
euh gaspillage c'est de l'exploitation
humaine c'est vraiment et pourtant les
les gens y vont et en même temps il
délaissent jusqu'à provoquer des
faillites d'autres marques plus
traditionnelles et ben tout ça c'est
c'est une incohérence qui est difficile
à à concilier parce que bah la logique
politique c'est que vous pouvez pas dire
aujourd'hui bah le pouvoir d'achat
finalement c'est pas si important que ça
parce que il faut qu'on consomme moins
c'est inaudible alors toutes les
générations ont leur incohérence et au
sein de toutes les générations on a tous
nos incohérences mais l'histoire de
Shine parce qu'elle est belle c'est une
une forme d'incohérence de la génération
de de des des ados ou jeunes adultes
d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire que sont
présentés comme la génération la plus
sensible aux questions de de de
réchauffement climatique mais qui
consomme chez Shine quoi oui alors tout
à fait il y a vraiment cette génération
qui est celle qui est la plus
sensibilisée à l'écologie mais il faut
les comprendre en fait ils ont pas envie
d'être dans le sacrificiel ils
comprennent les enjeux mais ils vont pas
sacrifier alors que leurs parents ont
tout consommé en fait c'est un peu ça
leur leur vision des des chosesou et
donc en effet 18 % des de la population
française a déjà acheté un objet sur
Shine donc en effet c'est beaucoup et
c'est une des premières enseignes pour
le marché des des jeunes dans dans la
mode mais finalement les jeunes ils ont
ils ont pas leurs placard plein hein il
faut juste savoir que vous utilisez 30 %
de vos placards tous les ans donc en
fait il il y a 70 % de ce que vous avez
chez vous que dont on ne se sert jamais
un jeune il a rien il débute dans la vie
donc il soit obligé de s'équiper c'est
assez logique donc on peut pas leur
reprocher de faire ce que les
générations d'avant ont fait donc oui il
y a il y a des contradictions mais en
fait ce qu'on a vu au gouvernement c'est
les mêmes que chacun se pose tout le
monde est dans la même contradiction on
va reparler et on va dézoomer un peu
plus tard on reparlera des notions de
décroissance ce que vous en pensez les
uns et les autres croissance verte
est-ce que ça existe est-ce que c'est
possible mais je voudrais rester sur
cette quand même ces campagnes de de
laadem et puis alors là on est on rentre
dans le dans la période des achats de
Noël donc cette marque Shine est-ce que
c'était possible de la cibler est-ce que
la campagne gouvernementale voyez ce que
je veux dire Guillaume Compin n'aurait
pas mieux fait de cibler spécifiquement
ces enseignes là peut-être que c'était
pas possible d'ailleurs juridiquement
mais je sais pas je suis pas dans la
tête du gouvernement effectivement je
pense que en terme de ouioui bah ce qui
est clair c'est qu'il y a des marques de
la de la fast fashion comme Shain et et
d'autres qui ont un impact délétaire sur
la planète l'industrie de de
l'habillement c'est c'est environ 8 %
des émissions l'industrie textile c'est
8 % des émissions de gris effet de ser à
travers la planète c'est un impact
majeur à la fois sur la planète mais
d'ailleurs aussi sur les droits humains
on a bien vu aussi ce qui sétait passé
avec le drame du Rana Plaza par exemple
il y a certaines années donc c'est une
industrie de la f fashion qu'il faut
absolument réguler il faut absolument
avoir des meilleures pratiques
relocaliser mais aussi tout simplement
réduire cette demande en temps réel qui
est incité aussi par par la la publicité
et toute cette injonction finalement à
consommer régulièrement changer de de
garde-robe régulièrement donc c'est tout
un modèle à à repenser mais ça ne passe
pas par une vision de la croissance qui
serait univoque et avec l'idée qu'il
faut absolument croître quoi qu'il en
coûte enfin selon nous la croissance en
fait ça veut tout et rien dire on n'est
pas forcément contre la croissance mais
la question c'est quelle de quelle
croissance on veut une croissance qui
répond ond aux besoins de base de
l'ensemble des individus à la fois en
France et et sur sur la planète ça nous
paraît souhaitable le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui au nom de la croissance
on va stimuler parfois des des
industries des multinationales qui ont
qui génèent des des revenus faramineux
et qui pour autant vont baser en partie
leur modèle sur la destruction de la
planète sur l'usage de ressources de
manière disproportionnée donc pour nous
si la croissance est à ce prix elle est
pas souhaitable à la fois pour la
planète mais aussi économiquement
puisque de toute façon c'est pas
soutenable pose la question des
externalités négatives on en parlera un
peu plus tard Mathieu il a juste un non
dit même dans le débat c'est que cette
transition écologique elle va détruire
des emplois elle va peut-être en créer
par la suite et on le souhaite il y a il
va bien y avoir un moment où ça va
détruire des emplois et ça personne ne
le dit jamais et on a là un gouvernement
qui devant le lobby des vendeurs de
vêtements et c'est très bien que le
lobby des vendeurs de vêtements défend
ses intérêts mais dit commence à céder
alors que le même gouvernement dans
d'autres secteurs nous invite à moins
consommer par des campagnes h
nouséé àff à dans les appart les mais
Prex 2 de plus il étai inutile c'est
exactement comme un polo inutile on nous
invite à moins consommer de cigarettes à
grand renfort de campagne en disant que
c'est pour l'intérêt collectif le bien
collectif mais l'impératif écologique
c'est pas un intérêt collectif ça c'est
pas un bien collectif donc il y a une
incohérence aussi dans la pratique du
gouvernement entre les bons secteurs et
les mauvais secteurs tout ça sous un
écran de fumée qui est de ne pas dire
que oui ça va détruire des emplois mais
qu'il faut que ça en recrée donc le
trouveon commment mais il y a même une
une incohérence ou un double langage je
sais pas de de de certaines marques
parce qu'il y a de plus en plus de de
marques parce qu'elle est belle qui là
on va parler de la seconde main c'est de
parce que c'était l'objet de la campagne
de laadem c'était plutôt que d'acheter
neuf acheter du recyclé bon très bien
mais il y a de plus en plus de marques
dans tous les secteurs qui qui créent
leur leur espace de seconde main leur
corner de seconde main pardon pour
l'anglicisme que ce soit dans les
magasins physiques ou sur leur sur leur
plateforme de vente oui je crois que
finalement les fabricants ils ont
compris en fait qu'on allait vendre
moins de biens neufs donc ils sont
obligés de d'emparer de s'emparer du
reste et notamment juste un chiffre hein
de depuis cette année le parc automobile
diminue en France c'est que ça fait un
moment que finalement on vend de moins
en moins d'objets en fait et c'est le
cas du vêtement parce que ça fait depuis
une quinzaine d'années qu'on en vend de
moins en moins donc en fait ce qu'on
possède on en possède de moins en moins
donc en fait les acteurs économiques ils
ont compris qu'il fallait aller sur
autre chose et en effet de la valeur on
peut très bien faire de la croissance en
allant sur de la valeur en vendant moins
de BI c'est pas c'est pas un cohérent de
se dire on fait la circularité et en
effec oui mais comment quand on est dans
un mod dans un modèle de de retail
pardon de de commerce ou le le le la
marque s'est créé sur le modèle de
vendre le plus de produits possible au
plus grand nombre le moins cher possible
par exle vendre en seconde vie ou et et
le et le commerçant il fait autant de
marge il y a pas de raison qui gagne pas
autant en vendant un bien qui est
d'occasion et en fait on voit bien que
c'est ça qui s'installe et c'est ça qui
marche 20 % de ce qu'on achète en volume
en en vêtement c'est de la seconde main
à Noël dernier 30 % des des cadeaux qui
ont été faits c'était de la seconde main
donc on voit bien que c'est quelque
chose qui on a l'impression que les
politiques publiques il sont un peu en
retard par rapport à des phénomènes qui
sont qui sont là réi Godo ça peut même
aller jusqu'à alors un changement plus
ou moins radical plus ou moins rapide du
modèle économique c'est passer de la de
l'achat de la possession à la location à
l'usage du produit ou oui mais je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit qui n'est pas un argument
contre la croissance la croissance va se
modifier mais de fait le on l'a vu avec
avec Barbie par exemple le capitalisme
il digère il est prêt à se contredire
mais il arrive toujours à retomber un
peu sur ses pattes parce que bah il va
s'adapter à ce que veulent les gens et
effectivement petit à petit le problème
c'est le court terme et le long terme on
aimerait que là parce qu'il y a une une
urgence climatique on aimerait que la
transition se fasse en 2 ans mais non
vous vous rendez compte c'est depuis la
première révolution industrielle que on
est dans une économie carbonée donc euh
ça se fera pas du jour au lendemain mais
on voit que c'est sans doute parce qu'on
a tardé à entendre les messages des
scientifiques qui nous al l'air depuis
des décennies aussi et puis ce que vous
disiez sur il faut donner de la valeur
aux choses si vous ne donnez pas de la
valeur à la pollution bah vous polluez
sans vous en préoccuper euh un autre
exemple c'est sur le sur l'automobile
effectivement non seulement les gens euh
achète moins d'automobiles mais les gens
n'attachent plus la même valeur à la
voiture ce qui fait que vous avez bah
des voitures milieu voire bat gamme qui
deviennent des voitures euh euh comme la
logane qui deviennent des voitur les
voitures des bobos parce que finalement
la mobilité on veut pas dépenser
beaucoup on sait que c'est pas terrible
mais si on s'il faut à tout prix avoir
une voiture et ben on va pas surinvestir
dans la voiture ça ce sont des
modifications qui sont qui ne vont pas
contre la croissance mais qui font que
ben voilà les que les gens s'adaptent HM
alors est-ce qu'on peut aller jusqu'à un
Noël vert on a lancé un peu ce défi à
Steve Jourdain qui va nous rejoindre qui
est juste derrière le rideau de de sens
public qui va faire de nouveau son
entrée sur le plateau bonsoir Steve re
bonsoir Steve alors un Noël
écooresponsable pas pas si facile c'est
ça non non bah Noël c'est déjà la magie
mais Noël c'est aussi un immense
festival du gaspillage Thomas on va voir
ça 20000 tonnes de papiers cadeaux sont
consommés chaque année en France pour
préparer emballer vos offrandes certains
sont recyclables mais pas tous beaucoup
partent à la poubelle à la poubelle
également le pas des fêes pas celui
seulement celui de de belleemaman près
d'un tiers des Français gaspillent de la
nourriture servie pendant les fêtes
juste après le repas ou après le passage
au frigo de manière générale les
festivités hivernales pèsent pour 1 %
des émissions de gaz à effet de ser
annuel pour un Français moyen c'est une
donnée qu'on n pas forcément en tête ça
se voit ça se lit d'ailleurs dans les
chiffres puisque seulement 10 % des
Français ajustent leur comportement aux
impératifs écologiques et on peut dire
que cette année il y aura plutôt un
ajustement
budgétaire ou économique oui pour ce
Noël pour le le Noël qui arrive le
budget moyen des Français pour les
cadeaux est en baisse il est de 426 € il
était de 446 € l'année dernière selon
Opinion Way cette baisse ne semble pas
venir d'une prise de conscience de
l'empreinte carbone de notre
consommation Thomas puisque selon le
même sondage un Français sur deux
achètera au moins une partie de ses
cadeaux sur la plateforme Amazon mais
sous le sapin il y aura aussi de la
seconde main on y vient et c'est une
vraie tendance de fond là encore
difficile de distinguer les raisons
écologiques des raisons financières près
de 40 % des Français sont prêts à offrir
des cadeaux d'occasion à leur proches
phénomène encore plus important chez les
plus jeunes puisque le chiffre monte à
52 % chez les moins de 35 ans en tête de
gondol on trouve les jouets et les
vêtements de business qui fonctionnent
très bien en ce qui concerne les
vêtements la plateforme vintage est
désormais le premier site euh
d'habillement de en ligne enfin sur
Internet c'est le premier site marchand
Texti en France devant le géant chinois
de la fast fashion chain ou Chine je
sais pas bien comment on prononce c'est
très loin devant l'enseigne Zara pour ce
qui est du marché du jouet là encore
l'occasion à le vent en poup l'année
dernière 4,7 % des ventes relevaient de
la seconde main plusieurs projections
anticipent un marché grimpant jusqu'à 15
% des transactions d'ici à 2030 merci
beaucoup Steve jourin pour tous ces ces
chiffres c'était passionnant Guillaume
Compain on revient à la question de de
l'impulsion
gouvernementale qu'est-ce qui manque
selon vous pour que cette appétant cet
appétit pour la seconde main prenne
encore plus de place puisquon dit il y a
finalement certaines entreprises qui le
font il y a une partie des Français qui
sont prêts qu'est- qu'est-ce qui manque
dans l'action gouvernementale d'après
vous ce qui est ce qui est sûr déjà dans
dans cette logique de transition c'est
qu'il faut proposer des mesures
structurelles aux françaises et aux
Français pour pouvoir mieux consommer et
moins consommer typiquement que ce soit
sur le sur le le textile et la seconde
main mais aussi par exemple sur les dé
placement donc notre mobilité que ce
soit sur notre logement aussi qui a une
empreunte carbone importante on peut pas
agir seul si on n pas par exemple de
transport en commun de maillage du
territoire qui est développé on sait que
la France par exemple a un réseau
ferroviaire historiquement très
important qui a été largement délaissé
ces dernières années on sait que sur le
logement le reste à charge quand il
s'agit de rénover son logement et et
pèse de manière démesurée sur les plus
modestes qui parfois on reste à charge
qui correspond à 10 ans de leur revenus
euh pour rénover de manière globale leur
leur leur maison ou leur appartement
donc on voit qu'il il y a besoin de
complément que ce soit des subventions
des des financements notamment dédiés au
plus modestes parce qu'il faut aussi que
la transition soit juste et il faut des
des politiques publiques qui soient qui
structurellement permettent de consommer
moins après ce qu'il faut aussi avoir en
tête et Monsieur le disait tout à
l'heure c'est que les le pouvoir d'achat
évidemment que tout le monde a a besoin
et et pour pour remplir ses besoins
vitaux d'avoir un minimum de de pouvoir
d'achat et d'ailleurs la la consommation
des plus modestes est bien plus faible
que celle des des plus riches il y a un
rapport d'Oxfam qui est sorti il y a 2
semaines qui montre que les 1 % les plus
riches à travers la planète émettent
autant que les 2 tiers de l'humanité et
si onission de gaz effet de ser de gaz
effet de serre bien sûr et si on on
prend ces chiffres à l'échelle française
les 1 % les plus riches de nos
concitoyens etmettent autant que 16 %
les plus modeste donc on voit aussi que
la transition elle pèse pas de manière
absolument symétrique sur toute la
population française et que c'est avant
tout les plus fortunés ceux qui ont le
plus à la fois de d'impact sur la
planète mais aussi qui ont les moyens de
de se passer d'un certain nombre de leur
ressources qui doivent faire davantage
l'effort ça nous semble être une mesure
à la fois de justice sociale mais aussi
pour gagner l'ensemble de nos citoyens
vers cette transition collective un
autre une autre donnée près d'un
Français sur TR a demandé une avance sur
salaire en novembre pour augmenter leur
pouvoir d'achat avant Noël parce qu'elle
est belle ça veut dire quoi c'estut dire
que avant d'être le Noël de la seconde
main c'est le Noël de l'inflation quand
même oui tout à fait on sait que on a
une inflation qui a atteint des records
notamment c'était en mars 2023 et on a
un pouvoir d'achat qui est en train de
ralentir on a 0 % de croissance de la
consommation cette année donc vous
imaginez bien qu'en moyenne c'est 0 % et
qu'il y a des gens qui consomment moins
on a 2/3 des Français qui se
restreignent en fait he en ce moment que
ce soit sur le marché de l'habillement
mais mais surtout sur des produits qui
sont nécessaires l'énergie et
l'alimentation c'est-à-dire que
l'alimentation l'inflation ne ralentit
pas du tout en fait on est toujours on a
même une hausse de l'inflation de 0,3 %
sur le panier des de l'alimentation au
mois d'octobre donc
on sent bien que finalement il y a des
secteurs sur lesquels on peut pas s'en
passer se loger et manger et là on ne
fait rien parce qu'en effet c'est
toujours en politique publique c'est
l'ordre de l'intime vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure c'est-à-dire que tout ce qui
concerne l'individu on veut pas faire
des faire de choses alors que faire une
politique agricole on peut le faire
faire une politique sur l'automobile on
arrive à le faire mais on narrive pas
finalement à à faire des des réformes
qui soient eng agente et qui pourrait en
effet faire payer plus cher ce qui a un
impact négatif et dont on peut se passer
et puis évidemment faire des taxes zéro
sur ce qui est indispensable et ça
permettrait quand même de d'arriver à
aller un peu plus vite sur la transition
écologique et évidemment il faut
soutenir les plus modestes parce qu'en
ce moment les inégalités s'accroissent
he ça a été montré par l'INC on voit
bien que avec le covid on a une
inégalité qui a augmenté et donc de plus
en plus de gens qui sont en situation de
Rémy Godo est-ce que cette transition
écologique elle rend les produits neufs
forcément plus chers est-ce que il y a
une inflation liée à la transition
écologique bien sûr il y a un grand
dénis de la part du politique et on
comprend pourquoi parce que ces réformes
sont impopulaires la transition
écologique c'est impopulaire et les gens
qu'est-ce qu'on constate c'est que c'est
un thème qui fait partir les gens au
rassemblement national j'ai pas envie de
de faire peur mais le rassemblement
national a compris ça et on fait un un
thème de un thme mais parce qu'on n pas
su le rendre désirable ou positif on
revient sur le côté anxiogène ou
culpabilisateur de fait la transition
coûte parce que ça consiste à surtaxer
ce qui qu'il faut faire tout ce qui est
carboné donc par exemple il faut oui le
le gouvernement s'est planté avec la
taxe carbone il faut faire la taxe
carbone il faut que demain l'essence
coûte plus cher oui mais la taxe carbone
ça envoie les gilets jaunes pendant
pendant des mois mais peut-être que la
taxe carbone n'a pas été bien faite
parce que Bercy qui veut toujours faire
de bonnes affaires c'est dit qu'il
allait garder une partie des recettes
pour boucher son déficit ce qu'il faut
faire c'est que bien évidemment il faut
aider les plus modestes donc la taxe
carbone si elle rapporte 100 il faut
redistribuer ces 100 éé mal expprimé
exprimé expliquer pardon et surtout mal
utilisé enfinelle dans dans sa
conception telle qu'on aurait dû
l'expliquer aux Français en disant on on
on vous demande un effort avec la
taxeband mais voilà où cet argent va
aller et uniquement pour les plus
modestes ou pour ceux qui vient mil
rural qui sont obligés de prendre leur
voiture et cetera et cetera si vous
dites aux gens qui sont obligés de
prendre leur voiture que demain ils vont
payer leur essence deux fois plus cher
ça peut pas passer ça ne peut pas passer
mais c'est un dénis général parce que la
trans pour voilà est-ce que c'est vrai
parce que là on a ça va être vrai pour
le logement regardez le gouvernement à
reculer sur les passoirs thermiques
parce que pour pour certaines personnes
les normes sur pour sur les passoirs
thermiques étaient insupportable c'est
c'est de fait très complexe parce que il
faut vraiment redistribuer l'argent pour
aider les plus modestes et en même temps
aller assez vite al je voudrais qu'on
qu'on parle autour d'un d'un mot le mot
décroissance jusqu'où il faut aller et à
quel point on doit changer de modèle
économique tiens on va écouter un
manifestant québécois qui dit oui il
faut aller jusqu'à les décroissant
c'était lors de la Journée de la Terre à
Montréal
écoutez mais ça prend pas avec le
système qu'on a ça prend des changement
radicaux puis ça prend vraiment une
décroissance économique parce qu'on peut
pas continuer comme ça à générer plus de
biens pour faire plus de profit en
polluant plus et je vous propose juste
après euh de revenir en France avec une
réaction celle de la première ministre
c'était fin août lors de la rentrée du
MDEF elle rejette ce terme de
décroissance au nom de notre modèle
social écoutez près de 6 milliards
d'euros qui sont d'ors et déjà prévus
aussi pour la décarbonation de notre
industrie et donc je pense que ce combat
d'une croissance respectueuse de la
planète et des enjeux climatiques il
faut qu'on la gagne ensemble
décroissance alors moi vous savez je
pense que tous ceux qui prôent la
décroissance devrai dire que la
décroissance c'est remettre en cause
notre modèle social et je ne sais pas
s'il existe une française ou un Français
qui accepterait qu'on remette en cause
ce bien très précieux qui est notre
modèle social donc sans décroissance je
vous le confirme Guillaume Compin la
décroissance risque-t-elle de remettre
en cause le modèle social français je
pense que le modèle social français il y
a énormément de façons de financ
évidemment ça passe par les cotisations
par un nombre de revenus qui sont ISS de
notre consommation mais déjà la première
chose c'est que qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire la croissance encore une fois enfin
on peut mettre différents mots
aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est le produit
intérieur brut on peut d'ailleurs
remettre en cause la définition du
produit intérieur brut est-ce qu'il faut
pas le réinventer c'est une vra question
exement nous on pense que c'est
important de pas avoir cette cette
vision évidemment très singulière et de
dire on va tout comptabiliser à travers
un seul indic ur qui n'a aucune notion
par exemple des enjeux de bien-être de
de développement humain qui va
comptabiliser à la fois la vente de
véhicules électrique mais aussi de
cigarette dans un même indicateur qui
agrège finalement le volume de de
production français donc si c'est cet
indicateur dont on parle qui ne fait
aucune différence entre ce qui est
souhaitable ou pas pour la planète mais
aussi pour les humains non on n veut pas
après financer le modèle social français
ça passe évidemment par un certain
nombre de de taxes notamment sur les
plus haut revenus qui en une une part
indécente de la de la richesse en France
mais d'ailleurs dans d'autres pays et
pourquoi ne pas les mettre aussi à
contribution pour financer notre
transition écologique notre modèle
social et c'est ce qu'on ce qu'on promet
par exemple à Oxfam un ISF vert
c'est-à-dire à la fois rétablir un impôt
sur la fortune qui serait un deur pour
les plus riches mais qui en plus serait
assorti d'une d'une part variable en
fonction des investissements carbonés ou
non carbonés de ces de ces milliardaire
et multimillionnaire c'est-à-dire qu'en
gros si votre patrimoine est fortement
basé sur des revenus de vos
investissements dans les énergies
fossiles ou ce genre d'industrie on
surtaxe ces dividendes parce queil y a
pas de de raison que on continue de
fonctionner selon ce modèle ouis votre
avis là-dessus tiens je rebondis sur
cette proposition d'Oxfam qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez ro non je pense que c'est
c'est complètement fou pourquoi la
décroissance ça serait un drame social
moi je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce
que dit avec ce que dit la première
ministre et je pense que bien sûr on
peut faire payer les plus riches mais
c'est c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt
parce que vous vous allez faire payer
3000 ou 350 ou 3500 milliardaires mais
le problème est beaucoup plus large et
tout le monde va devoir payer et vous
allez devoir payer parce que tout le
monde pollue après qu'il a des
compensations une fois de plus oui bien
sûr il en faut c'est la seule solution
pour que ça soit accepté mais c'est pas
en taxe on peut taxer les riches mais
c'est pas c'est pas une solution de fait
on ne sait pas faire sans la sans sans
la croissance et je pense que c'est pour
ça que l'Élysée a surréagi à à
l'histoire des de vendeurs c'est que
c'est que le terme décroissance il est
très très connoté c'est un peu une
utopie c'est il y a eu il y a eu ce ce
mouvement dans les années 70 le rapport
midos qui nous disait qu'on était au
bord du au bord du goufre qu'il fallait
faire attention aux ressources de la
planète ça a été une mode ça a été une
mode qui était annonciatrice des chocs
pétrolier ça a été une mode qui était
sur sur le sur l'idéologie de de M68
chez nous par exemple et puis qu'on a
oublié on est passé il avait peut-être
une partie du message qui était juste et
qu'on a passé s'est avéré que dans le
rapport porm d'eau il y avait beaucoup
de choses qui qui se sont avéré fausses
sur le sur l'épuisement des ressources
sur l'épuisement des matères prières on
est un peu quand même non bah si on vous
dit dans les années0 dans les années 70
dans 20 ans il y aura plus de cuivre il
y aura beaucoup moins de pétrole et donc
notre économie va s'effondrer le rapport
mid s'est trompé donc c'est c'est je dis
pas c'était une autre échelle de temps
gu vou réagir changer changer la
croissance c'est une chose et
d'ailleurs vous êtes vous défendez une
croissance verte ou vous défendez la
décroissance parce que si vous défendez
la croissance verte vous défendez la
croissance si vous défendez la
décroissance bon il y a il faut même pas
parler d'emploi vert de croissance verte
il faut être logique ouais Guillaume
compa enfin moi j'ai enfin j'ai du mal à
comprendre vous considérez que soit une
mode on est quand même face à une 6e
extinction de masse de la biodiversité
il y a des des millions de personnes si
vous allez dire ça aux millions de
personnes qui font face aux pertes et
dommages lié au changement climatique
c'est-à-dire des des communautés par
exemple dans les dans le Pacifique qui
font face à une montée des eau qui a
détruit leur habitats qui euh réduit
leur leurs états parfois à de dev voir
changer de territoire parce que le
l'océan les les a empêché d'habiter sur
leur sur leur territoire encestro si
vous parlez de des des des milliers de
personnes qui sont décédées suite à des
événements climatiques extrêmes ces
dernières années 90 % d'ailleurs de ces
personnes étaient situées dans des pays
du Sud euh je pense quand même que sur
certains d' aspects le rapport midos
s'est pas trompé et on le voit
d'ailleurs le JC lui-même dit que
réduire notre demande énergétique euh
pourrait contribuer à 40 à 70 % de la
baisse d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre qui nous permettra de tenir
l'accord de Paris donc euh c'est quand
même extrêmement important de réduire
dans tous les cas notre niveau de
demande et et et pour autant est-ce que
vous employez le mot décroissance parce
que effectivement c'est c'est de presque
devenu un gros mot donc est-ce que vous
osez l'employer justement je pense que
c'est comme les sujets nucléaaires des
croissances ça cristallise beaucoup les
tensions euh nous comme je disais tout à
l'heure ça dépend ce qu'on met derrière
la croissance évidemment que je parler
des pays du Sud beaucoup de pays du Sud
souhaitent pouvoir croître pour
atteindre un certain niveau de
développement de bien-être et ça nous
paraît tout à fait légitime après si
c'est pour encore une fois avoir une
dimension illégitime à quel niveau
justement par exemple on s'inspire
beaucoup de la théorie du donut donc ça
a été développé par une
économiste qui montre en fait un ce qui
nous paraît être un équilibre
souhaitable entre un seuil de besoins
donc typiquement l'accès à la santé pour
tous l'accès à un accès universel à
l'énergie puisqu'on sait qu'encore
aujourd'hui 700 millions de personnes à
travers le monde n'ont pas un accès au
quotidien à ectricité et par ailleurs
des un respect justement des limites
planétaires ce qui passe par ne pas
dépasser un certain seuil d'émission de
gaz à effet de C mais je parlais tout à
l'heure de biodiversité on parlait tout
à l'heure de ressources critiques de de
de cycle de l'eau de l'azote c'est tout
ce nom enfin c'est tout un ensemble en
fait de de dimensions sur lesquelles il
faut être très attentif pour ne pas
menacer les conditions de vie sur Terre
ce mot décroissance comment il est perçu
par les par par les Français par les
consommateurs on voit qu'il revient
quand même dès qu'il y a une petite
crise économique on sent bien il il
existait il il revient je pense qu'en
effet il faut pas utiliser ce terme là
parce que ça fait peur mais c'est en
effet c'est mesurer une croissance
autrement en faitin et je pense qu'en
effet on peut très bien donner de la
valeur sans forcément refuter le le PIB
hein la mesure du PIB en changeant en
fait les le type de biens qui sont
vendus et en effet si on si on vend des
services au lieu de vendre des biens
physiques déjà on aura un impact plus
faible donc c'est on voit bien c'est
déjà en train de se mettre en place on
voit bien sur l'énergie on a accepté de
dire on va diminuer la consommation
d'énergie donc c'est bien que il y a
derrière un service rendu qui est payé
autrement et qu'on va arriver à faire
cette chose-là sur d'autres secteurs
mais en effet n'utilisons pas le terme
décroissances disons qu'on fait une
croissance d'un autre ordre et moi je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord en disant
qu'on va détruire des emplois on disait
ça au moment où internet est arrivé
internet allait détruire des emplois et
ça a pas été la réalité parce qu'en fait
on modifie pour faire du bio il y a
besoin de beaucoup plus de main d'œuvre
que pour faire autre chose donc il y a
il y a pas forcément de destruction de
l'emploi en allant vers une transition
écologique il faut faire confiance à aux
entrepreneur pour ne pas tout tout tout
casser en faisant une transition
écologique Rémy Godo est-ce que on on
doit changer
d'indicateur on parlait des externalités
négatives est-ce qu'il faut ça ça va du
produit intérieur brut c'est intégrer
finalement changer de de modèle de
croissance et et ça va même jusqu'à un
produit ou au prix d'un produit
c'est-à-dire on on va intégrer euh
l'effet sur la santé par exemple s'il
est négatif d'un d'un produit à son prix
je je sais pas trop sur les indicateurs
parce que c'est franchement très
complexe ces indicateurs existent et
pourtant le bon vieux PIB il est
toujours là en revanche il faut
valoriser les choses détruire la planète
épuiser la planète ça doit avoir un un
coup qui si on estime que la planète est
en danger doit devenir exorbitant et à
ce moment-là le système va se va va se
mettre en place moi je suis au nom des
libertés je n'ai pas envie que le
gouvernement me dise ne fais pas ça
c'est mal et je te l'interdis en
revanche que le gouvernement dit disent
si vous prenez l'avion qui est un moyen
de transport très polluant vous allez le
payer mais alors à un prix tellement
exorbitant que vous allez faire trois
voyages dans votre vie oui je suis je je
trouve ça logique les entreprises seront
très bien vous savez les entreprises ne
gaspillent pas si elles arrivent à
gaspiller à ne pas gaspiller et être
beaucoup plus efficace elles feront même
plus de profit si elles consomment moins
d'énergie qu'ell P de plus en plus cher
et bien ell elles seront plus compétitif
donc les entreprises ont même intérêt à
all dans est-ce qu'il faut pas quand
même changer le le le le le thermomètre
en quelque sorte il y a des comptable
qui réfléchissent à à une nouvelle forme
de comptabilité qui intègre justement
cette notion de d'externalité négative
ou de performance extrafinancière aussi
on vous butez sur le pouvoir d'achat sur
la question du pouvoir d'achat si vous
me dites euh moi bobo euh aisé euh mais
réfléchis à autre chose si on valorise
le fait que tu que tu partes à la
campagne que tu fasses une retraite et
que tu bah moi je peux dire oui mais euh
le problème c'est qu'il y a des gens qui
regardent leur feuill de leur feuill de
salaire c'est c'est c'est le le fameux
débat entre la fin du monde et la fin du
mois c'est qu'il y a des gens qui
regardent leur feuille de salaire à la
fin à la fin de euh à la fin du mois et
puis d'autre part il faut faire
attention il faut pas il y a certes il y
a les Ultra riches qui peut-être
dépensent s sans considérer mais il faut
prendre aussi on a vu des gens qui se
battaient pour le nutella on a dit oh là
là quelle horreur quelle horreur mais
même quand vous avez peu peu de de
moyens vous pouvez aussi vouloir acheter
des biens qui vous valorisent des biens
que vous associez au désir pourquoi
interdire ça c'est très complexe très
très complexe Guillaume Compin sur sur
cette notion de de nouveaux indicateurs
euh notamment comptable pour les
entreprises est-ce qu'il faut faudrait
se battre pour obtenir ça on pense
d'autant plus qu'en fait cette
comptabilité qui prennent plus en compte
justement les l'impact sur les
ressources c'est aussi dans l'intérêt de
ces entreprises de bien mesurer euh la
destruction potentiel des ressources sur
lesquelles en fait elles construisent
aussi une partie de leur valeur à
travers leur utilisation donc en fait
c'est aussi internalisé finalement dans
le la gouvernance de ces entreprises
l'impact sur la planète mais aussi sur
d'autres ressources et donc ça nous
paraît très souhaitable et d'ailleurs on
pense aussi que c'est important que les
entreprises aient des plans de
transition qui soient contraignant
c'est-àd qu'elles doivent dévoiler
quells sont leurs ition pour baisser par
exemple le niveau de elles sont nombreus
à faire elles sont nombreuses à le faire
déjà il faut que ce soit contraignant
contant sorti de plan d'investissement
c'estàd qu'on peut toujours déclarer
qu'on va être neutre en carbone en 2050
comme le fait le font beaucoup
d'entreprises d'ailleurs des énergies
fossiles alors qu'elle Contin continuent
d'investir massivement dans leur
développement donc
donc vous me tendez une perche je vous
propose d'entendre le patron de Total
énergie là-dessus Patrick Pouan qui
mettait en avance à l'occasion de
l'assemblée générale ces investissements
dans les énergies renouvelables en 2022
une nouvelle fois notre compagnie a été
la mur qui a investi le plus pour
construire le modèle énergétique de
demain qui sera basé sur l'électricité
notamment à partir de capacités
renouvelabl et de nouvelles molécules
bacarbon près de 4 milliards de dollars
ont été investis en 2022 et ce chiffre
va encore progresser en 2023 pour
atteindre 5 milliards de
dollarsy ce même patri dit c'est
uniquement lorsque nous aurons un
système décarboné que nous pourrons
arrêter pétrole bah oui moi je je trouve
que pouyanet est très courageux et qui
dit des choses de bon sens après il y a
deux philosophies qui s'opposent bon
classique il y a ceux qui vous disent on
va pas austraciser les entreprises qui
s'adaptent mais qui s'adaptent dans le
temps et puis à ceux qui vous disent il
faut tout de suite interdire les
producteurs de pétrole mais du pétrole
on en a besoin aujourd'hui donc pourquoi
dire à total mais arrêtez de produire du
pétrole alors qu'il y a une
demande le problème c'est que si moi je
suis à la campagne que j'ai une voiture
il va bien falloir que je fasse rouler
cette voiture tant que j'ai le droit
d'utiliser cette voiture ou parce que je
n'ai pas les moyens d'utiliser une
voiture électrique donc pouyanet il dit
ça mais en même temps c'est l'entreprise
en France qui investit le plus dans les
énergies dans les énergies renouvlbles
effectivement c'est pas faux vous
vouliez intervenir c'est le dernier mot
il nous reste 30 secondes juste pour
rappeler que Total Energie encore un
quart de ses investissements c'est dans
des nouveaux projets d'énergie fossile
qui nous emmène à 30 40 ans c'est
complètement incompatible avec les
trajectoires de respect de l'accord de
Paris et en plus de ça on sait que des
grandes compagnies des énergies fossiles
savent depuis 50 ans euh la réalité du
changement climatique il y a des études
internes qui le montte et on tout fait
pour qu'elle ne soit pas publique donc
elle contribue quand même d'une certaine
manière à ce que la demande continue
c'est tout dans leur intérêt donc c'est
un peu hypocrite de notre point de vue
de dire que c'est uniquement la faute
des consommateurs merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à à ce débat qui
était passionnant je vous dis à bientôt
sur sur Public Sénat euh demain noter
que l'invité de la de la matinale ce
sera Jean-Louis Bruguier l'ancien juge
antiterroriste il sera face à Orian
mansini à 8h sur notre antenne merci de
votre fidélité belle soirée à toutes et
à
tous